Hi. My name is Draško Proferović. I'm a
staff engineer at Pinterest.
Today, I'll cover Medic for Apache
Spark,
which is our agentic diagnostics tool
built to troubleshoot Spark failures.
We'll dive into why we built the Medic,
the journey from prototype to the
current architecture,
lessons learned along the way, and
what's next.
A bit of background about myself.
I had the opportunity to work at a few
companies under the data platform org.
Despite many differences between those
companies, there's at least one
similarity.
The high bar for providing quality
support to partner teams who rely on the
infrastructure owned by the data
platform org.
I'm sure I'm not alone when I say that
the support rotation feels like a
never-ending stream of questions or
problems to resolve.
Moreover, it's easy to forget how
difficult it is to troubleshoot Spark
or any distributed system for that
matter.
This is particularly true for anyone
just getting started with the framework.
The other challenge with supporting a
load-bearing system comes down to
ambiguous priorities.
Do you focus on helping one team with
their failing job, or do you unblock
another team with a looming deadline?
It's not always straightforward to rank
these asks,
but as humans, we often have to decide
how we'll spend our time.
The same is not true for LLMs.
We can easily scale out knowledge and
capabilities on demand.
Our vision for a diagnostics agent
was to ask it simply, "Why did a job
fail?" and get back a deep research
document which provides evidence on the
root cause of the failure.
The agent would also need to provide
suggested fixes that are grounded in the
context of the job.
Needless to say, this agent would need
to be available on all the surfaces
where our users operate today, like
Slack or the Airflow UI to name a few.
We started by exposing our data
resources by way of the model context
protocol as a way to connect them to the
LLMs.
At this point, we could start an LLM
conversation with the MCP tools enabled
and ask the model to reason about our
Spark job.
This worked in practice, but it required
a lot of careful prompting from the
human operator.
We extended our prototype by creating a
single reasoning and acting agent, React
for short.
The agent was given a single prompt,
which embodied the problem-solving
approach it would take,
how to structure the responses as a
report, and specific examples to common
failure patterns.
At this point, we had enough
capabilities to start trialing the
solution with our beta users.
From those early trials, we found a lot
of shortcomings with our solution.
Prompt tuning became unsustainable.
One prompt had to do everything,
and adding detail in one area degraded
the behavior in another.
Response quality was inconsistent.
Sometimes analysis was shallow or other
times too verbose.
We lacked controls to keep the agent on
track.
And we often hit context window issues
for production jobs. As an example,
large tool outputs from logs would click
quickly consume tokens and brought a
halt to the agent's reasoning.
Lastly, our end-to-end testing strategy
up to this point relied on manual tests
from production.
This felt anecdotal since production
data would be retentioned away.
Overall, it was hard to know if changes
broke earlier wins.
To improve the system, we invested in
observability and testability.
We used open telemetry to publish traces
to LangFuse.
And by viewing the agent's execution as
a waterfall diagram of steps, we could
better understand the cause of lower
quality responses.
The reliance on manual end-to-end
testing highlighted the need for a more
reliable and scalable solution.
We built an end-to-end test harness to
snapshot production state.
And we could codify expectations as
offline evaluations.
Lastly, this allowed us to tune our
prompt based on the results.
In practice,
the end-to-end test harness is simple.
In record mode, the agent calls real
downstream systems, and tool responses
are captured as fixtures.
These are then saved to the file system
and checked in as code.
Playback mode, the agent runs against
fixtures instead of production data,
but this time performs the analysis and
generates the report.
The test suite then grades the report
based on the offline evals we have
authored.
For example, an offline eval might check
for a limit of three suggested fixes.
The eval would score lower if the agent
provided too many fixes towards managing
the verbosity of the final report.
Our end-to-end tests allowed us to
quantify quality instead of relying on
intuition.
And as we grew our test coverage, we
gained confidence that improvements did
not introduce regressions.
Once we had the testing coverage in
place, we invested deeper in our
handling of logs.
Logs are noisy, and many exceptions we
see in logs are benign. So, simply
focusing the last exception may not
always be suitable.
Initially, we kept it simple with a
heuristics based approach using regex to
filter out certain exceptions.
But, this didn't scale well.
Instead, we built the exception
classifier pipeline.
The core idea was we would learn which
exceptions commonly appear in successful
jobs,
treat those as likely red herrings, and
filter them out in the future analysis.
The agent would fingerprint and cluster
exceptions, then rank them based on
content relevance, and how recently they
occurred compared to the termination of
the job.
The agent stopped consuming logs
directly, and instead was given two MCP
tools.
Get the top K truncated exceptions,
or get full log details for a specific
exception.
This resulted in an improvement to our
signal-to-noise ratio, and reduced the
chance of the LLM to anchor its
investigation with a misleading
exception.
Like logs, we found that we could
improve the overall quality by investing
in how we handle metrics.
Raw time series metrics are not context
window friendly.
Simply feeding the raw data to an LLM
works in the small scale, but fails for
long-running jobs in production.
Not to mention, it's horribly token
inefficient.
The approach we took was to perform
metrics analysis in a quarantine
sub-agent.
We would convert the raw time series
data into graphs, which are then
collaged into an
final image.
The appearance of which isn't much
different than a Grafana dashboard,
albeit with annotations that we found
useful, like calling out the min and max
values.
The image is then attached the LLM
conversation,
and we would prompt the model to reason
about patterns in the the
Images worked better because we could
guarantee how many input tokens would be
used for analyzing any given Spark job
irrespective of its duration.
Examples of useful signals we would be
able to get included executors dropping
down to zero or near zero,
long plateaus or bottlenecks,
effectively any resource behavior
inconsistent with healthy progress.
Our sub agent would summarize its
findings and return the results back to
the parent agent, thereby ensuring the
context window is kept healthy.
Lastly,
we overhauled our agent harness. We went
from a single react agent with
multi-agent architecture.
This was accomplished by building on top
of LangGraph's deep agent library.
Each agent now had a dedicated prompt
and a subset of MCP tools.
Meanwhile, the deep agent library itself
provided built-in tools to keep the
agent on track, like a to-do list or a
virtual file system.
This approach mirrors what we come to
expect from our coding tools like Cloud
Code or Codex, to name a few.
We could finally decompose our single
prompt into specialized roles.
This refactor provided clear separation
of each agent and it made it easier for
developers to maintain each prompt
separately while performing focused
testing on the system
using our end-to-end test harness.
A pleasant consequence of this
architecture was that the effort to
expand the scope of the project was as
simple as adding a new prompt.
And this is how we were able to extend
the Medic to also help users optimize
their Spark SQL jobs.
Our workflow started starts with the
user's request entering the system,
whereupon intent is classified as either
requiring a simple answer to a question
or a deep diagnostic session.
If it's the latter, the triage agent
determines the Spark job's life cycle
state.
And if it's failed, it'll use a subset
of tools to generate a set of failure
hypotheses.
Each hypothesis is researched in
parallel where we gather evidence to
validate it.
These research agents then return a
score and a root cause.
The supervisor selects the highest
confidence root cause and invokes the
healer agent to offer remediations based
on runbooks ingested into our vector
database.
Lastly, the supervisor agent would
assemble the final report ensuring
proper formatting.
The multi-agent architecture proved very
effective offering us the greatest
control over the system's behavior.
Enhancements to log
handling led to substantial reduction in
inaccurate root causes.
We trialed using LangGraph's workflows
to make the agent more deterministic,
but this approach proved to be brittle
compared to the reasoning and acting
agent paradigm.
What we're experimenting with now is
incorporating user feedback from prior
sessions to automatically improve the
agent.
Lastly, we see a broader opportunity to
apply this pattern to other distributed
systems like Flink and Trino.
Medic for Apache Spark project was made
possible by the hard work from these
contributors.
Thank you for your time.